everyone um
hi everyone welcome to the Friday
morning session of the 19th annual is TF
conference at the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies we're
really glad that you could join us this
morning our theme this year is food and
forest cultivating resilient landscapes
today we're going to start with a talk
by Anna herfurth followed by a panel on
beyond yields food security and
resilience after lunch we'll have a
panel on reconciling interests at the
landscape scale you'll then have a
chance to participate in either a
workshop on facilitating
multi-stakeholder dialogues or two of
three discussions about nutrition gender
or rights will end the day with the
reception and a poster session if you're
at any point unsure where to go or
what's going on look for at Yale a staff
member you can recognize us by the green
dots on our ID badges and I want to
mention that the bathrooms the women's
bathroom is right back there in the
men's bathroom is outside the auditorium
in the back and we're so pleased to have
a noir fourth year with us to give this
morning's introductory address she'll
also be moderating one of the afternoon
discussions on nutrition and
conservation with Selena Ahmed he'll be
talking in panel one anna is a
consulting specializing in nutrition as
a multi-sectoral is she related to
agriculture and the environment she
consults for the World Bank the UN Food
and Agriculture Organization and USA IDs
spring project she's also a visiting
fellow at Cornell University she's
worked with universities nonprofit
organizations agencies of the United
Nations and cgiar on nutrition policy
and programs in Africa South Asia and
Latin America ana
thank you is this can you hear me
through the mic okay so thank you julian
and karen and all the organizers of this
conference I think it's really wonderful
that you're having a theme on food and
and forests and I'm so pleased to be
here because usually i'm surrounded by
the nutrition world and to a lesser
extent the agriculture world and I as
you'll see through the presentation I
believe that sustainable food production
is critical for many reasons including
nutrition and I really believe that we
need enhanced collaboration with
conservation so I'm so happy to see
these themes coming together here at
Yale for this conference so what I'm
going to do in this presentation is tell
you giving an introduction to what I
live in brief in the nutrition world
what you know food security and
nutrition means and what the global
movement is on those agendas and I also
look forward to learning a lot from you
from more of the forestry in
conservation tonight on how we can come
together and I'd also like to
acknowledge my collaborator Selena Ahmed
and I've I always learned a lot from her
she's an expert in conservation biology
and biodiversity so we thought through a
lot of these ideas together that I'm
going to talk about today so since we're
here to talk about food and forests I
think we might as well start by talking
about what's food what do we mean what
do we mean by food and why are we
talking about food so it has something
to do with human well-being and I
believe that one of the best ways to
think about human well-being is
nutrition because it reflects so much of
your internal and external environment
and determines so much of human
potential so I'll tell you more about
what I mean by that but just think to
yourself for a moment
when you hear the word food think about
your own life what what does food mean
so just think about it a hold of thought
and I was thinking about this myself you
know what what do I mean when I talk
about food and I think for me I could
best say what what I think food is is
something that we eat to be nourished
and food security is something that has
to include that idea and the fortunately
the agreement on what food security
means agreed by 182 heads of state and
the UN really does include that concept
of food is something you need to be
nourished so I think we should start by
getting on the same page about what is
food security and this is the definition
that was agreed to by you know all of
all the countries at the world foods on
my back in 1996 and it still is what
institutions have signed on to so if
we'd secure it exists when all people at
all times have physical and economic
access to sufficient safe and nutritious
food to meet dietary needs and food
preferences for a healthy and active
life this may be a little bit different
from what you what's commonly kind of
used as a term food security often there
are two words in this in particular they
get forgotten and those are physical
access to food so we we definitely have
moved towards knowing that economic
access incomes are important for
security but that's not enough you also
need to have physical access to be able
to conveniently get nutritious food and
if you're living in a very remote place
where markets far away you don't
necessarily have physical access even
though you may have economic access and
then nutritious food so it's not just
about calories it's about all of the
foods that you need for a healthy and
active life so too
to really I think this is such an
important concept to keep in mind that
we're when we talk about food security
that we're talking about nutritious
diets I was thinking you know maybe
something you can always remember about
how what food security really means is
how many of you when you have packed
your suitcases for a trip to a tropical
country have put in some extra granola
bars power bars and peanut butter and
maybe vitamins in your suitcase I
definitely have and why do we do that
it's because we are we are worried that
when we get to a new place we may be
temporarily food insecure we may be
unable to access sufficient safe and
nutritious food so this is a we talk
about coping mechanism sometimes this is
you know a way to cope and make sure
that we have food security but just you
know you can hold that in your mind for
when you hear food security what does
that really mean and then also oh so yes
summarizes consistent access to diverse
diets and diets are then the link
between food security and nutrition so
diets are not only influenced by the
kinds of foods that you have access to
but they're also influenced by your
environment and your internal needs so
your physical environment what kind of
food is available accessible convenient
your social environment what kind of
food is socially acceptable and are most
people eating and your culture so what
kind of food is acceptable to you so
maybe if you go to the you know amazon
rainforest maybe something that people
would be eating our roasted roasted
caterpillars is that something that is
going to go into your diet is that
something that fits with your culture
that you're going to accept and it may
depend on social environment and who
else is eating with you as well so diets
really reflect to the internal
individual needs and the external
environment and they is as I says the
link to from food security to nutrition
so this basic framework is a
nutritionist worldview and I'll show you
where food security and diet fit in so
the the mantra of nutritionist is food
health and care because access to food
which is food security maternal and
child care practices and also health
services and environment healthy
environments all contribute to your diet
and your health and together those are
what determine your nutrition because
you may have very good food security you
may eat a good diet but if you are very
sick if you have diarrhea you may not be
absorbing the nutrients in that food and
you may end up having poor nutrition and
also the kind of food that you end up
eating depends on how you're being fed
if your small child by probably your
mother or your caretakers so food health
and care ultimately determine nutrition
and just to show how that fits with the
healthy environments yet they have to be
free from contaminants and disease
vectors so they don't contribute to poor
health and also this will come up a
little bit later as well women's
decision making power income in time and
knowledge also are something important
and that will come up later and again
this is food security so the the top of
this framework here nutrition I'm going
to talk a little bit more about what
that means and a lot of times it's
reflected in body size nutrition is
often mesh it measure nutrition in terms
of some child's growth or body size or
biochemical indicators in the blood of
iron status or vitamin E status and this
is a lot of times actually nutrition is
invisible so here you might think that
this is a older
brother and a younger brother but in
fact these two children are the same age
they're both three years old and this
child was was malnourished as a baby and
as a result is severely stunted so
stunted means having low height for age
so this child is shorter than that he
should be compared to normal growth
which is his friend here but just
looking at that child it's you know he's
not terribly skin and bones you wouldn't
necessarily know that this child is
stunted unless you knew how old he was
so okay if stunting malnutrition a lot
of times a small body size why is that
important so he's you know he's
surviving he's overcome this period of
malnutrition but what does it actually
what what's the danger and the
consequences of malnutrition so it took
a while for nutrition community to
really get our story straight on this
and there's some very significant
research that showed so this is what
used to be considered the cause of child
mortality so you have all of these
infectious diseases and nutrition is
nowhere on here severe and nutrition and
actual starvation accounts for very very
few deaths in the world so you know this
nutrition have anything to do with child
death well it turns out it has a lot to
do with child mortality malnutrition is
actually the single largest cause of
child mortality because it interacts
with disease so if you have a disease
any one of these diseases and are also
malnourished then you're much more
likely to actually die from that disease
so child deaths from infectious disease
are often the combination of the disease
itself and malnutrition so research that
showed this interaction really this was
in the mid 90s that showed that
malnutrition is actually extremely
important to to life
and then also beyond just the
life-and-death issue there are
consequences of malnutrition even for
those who survive so child child
malnutrition is associated with
increased mortality increased illness
also reduce cognitive development so
stunting early on usually people lose
the ability to develop fully cognitively
lose IQ points and that's been well
documented reduced schooling so beyond
just the physical mental ability also
reduced opportunities through schooling
children who are malnourished go to
school later reduced worker revenues so
over a lifetime usually more than a ten
percent loss in income from early
malnutrition and then that translates to
reduce gdp at the national level of two
to three percent which our world back
world bank estimates and this is just to
show where the malnutrition primarily
occurs there's a lot of focus on
sub-saharan Africa and South Asia a
little bit in Latin America and
Southeast Asia as well but really a lot
of the focus and a lot of these
discussions is subtenant Africa South
Asia and that's reflected again this is
the red dots our child mortality and
also it's related to poor poor diets of
course so vitamin A deficiency is found
in the same same regions and anemia and
anemia would have to do with both poor
diets and also infectious diseases that
contribute to that a few years ago
nutrition had a real turning point with
the lancet series on maternal and child
undernutrition and there's I don't think
there's ever been a series of papers
that's been this influential at least in
my knowledge so this series of papers
really it did a couple of things it
pulled together all the research on what
we know about the causes and
consequences
of malnutrition and for whom those
happen most and where the consequences
are most severe and it clarified that
there's a window of opportunity for
nutrition of pregnancy and the first two
years of life so from minus 9 to 24
months and somebody looked at that time
region was very clever and realized that
it's a thousand days so now we talk
about it as a thousand days and this is
when malnutrition is most likely to
occur and when it has the most severe
and often irreversible consequences and
it also defined a set of evidence-based
direct nutrition interventions to reach
that age range so things like enhanced
breastfeeding things like delivering
vitamin E supplements things like
curative services for malnourished
children and those direct nutrition
interventions led to a coalescence of
advocacy around the target age range and
also the interventions at the same time
there was a global food crisis going on
around two thousand eight so it just
sort of happened that this nutrition
advocacy in the global food crisis
growing at the same time and there's
this opportunity for nutrition to be
kind of insert as a corollary objective
to new agriculture and food security
initiatives that were coming out of that
food price crisis so here's there's now
the thousand days initiative from that
pregnancy first years of life time
period Hillary Clinton you know speaking
improving nutrition for mothers and
children's were the most cost-effective
impactful tools we have for poverty
alleviation and sustainable development
a lot of advocacy around the thousand
days there there's this little girl here
who is supposed to you know rouse
compassion and interest in this and then
we also have agriculture programs
there's the same little girl nutrition
has become sort of part of agriculture
programs and also agriculture has kind
of infiltrated into nutrition programs
here so you see the this you know
picture supposed to represent who
who were talking about within the
scaling of nutrition movement and that's
that's also like a thousand days
movements is this scaling of nutrition
movement is something new that came out
of this a new evidence base from 2008
and it is a coalition of partners
there's over 100 partners who have
signed on to the scaling of nutrition
movement the scaling up nutrition
framework and this is this has never
happened before in nutrition so this is
really like there's a lot of energy
around nutrition that hasn't been there
before and this scaling up nutrition
framework which all of these
institutions signed basically says we
need two approaches to improve nutrition
and the first is to scale off these
evidence-based direct interventions
nutrition specific missions we call them
for prevention and treatment the highest
priority of the first thousand days but
then it also says what everyone signed
onto here to take a multi sectoral
approach to nutrition primarily through
agriculture and social protection health
education water gender governance all of
these sectors if you remember the
framework all of those lead into the
underlying causes of nutrition food
health and care so we can't ignore those
however at this point the Sun framework
really focuses on the first set so the
nutrition specific interventions and
it's very very specific it has this
table that says this is what we're going
to do we're going to do breast feeding
we're going to do vitamin A supplements
we're going to do zinc we're going to do
iron cell ionization you know all of
this all of this is great but then when
you get to the multi-sectoral side it's
just we need to do it but there's
nothing about what we do or how we do
that so how do we improve nutrition from
agriculture I mean it's clear to people
agriculture is essential for nutrition
as a producer of food there's a large
proportion of the world's poor who are
farmers at particularly now there's
renewed investments in agriculture so
there's actually an opportunity to do
something where as in you know 80s and
90s there wasn't even much going on in
agriculture let alone
so now we have the opportunity to to
work with agriculture and and now I'm
just going to go through a little bit of
why what are what are people saying
about you know why do we need to
especially work with agriculture for
nutrition I mean why why isn't enough it
enough just to have this agricultural
investments why does nutrition even we
need to be partnering with these things
that you know if AG is just producing
food isn't that enough well it's
definitely not enough because the
current state is that we have 870
million hungry in the world and two
billion have hidden hunger which is a
term that we use about micronutrient
deficiencies so being low in essential
vitamins and minerals you can't
necessarily see it but it's going to
lead to that reduced cognitive
development reduced incomes reduce
cooling so hidden hunger and then also
there's a billion overweight and obese
and that's growing every day so when we
invest in agriculture nutrition impacts
might be positive or negative and it's
it you have to look at the whole picture
of nutrition and there's a lot of
evidence that calorie production and
economic growth are not sufficient to
solve nutrition problems and these are
these have been the main goals so far
calorie production is related to
undernutrition there's a positive
relationship as as you increase the
amount of calories available on a nation
it improves nutrition at low levels of
calories that's when there are severe
deficits and calories and this is on
average so in any given country this
relationship may be stronger or weaker
but the Millennium Development Goal one
to have poverty and hunger by 2015 when
we look at the two indicators there the
percent hungry and the percent
underweight since we're close to 2015
now we can see there are 21 countries
that have already met the goal of
reduced hunger but of those only sick
are on track to meet the underweight
goal so just that shows you that you can
improve you can meet the millennium
development goal and for hunger and by
producing a lot of calories but that's
rarely going to do much about nutrition
so the country there are very few
countries that have actually met both
goals and why is that well there's this
is for sub-saharan Africa calorie
production usually focuses on starchy
roots and cereals and what we can see
here is that the amount of starchy roots
of cereals available per capita if it
were equally distribution distributed
which of course it's not but if it were
there would actually be enough more than
enough for everybody in sub-saharan
Africa but then when you look at other
dietary components so pulses and fruits
and vegetables these dotted lines
represent what would be needed for in
the case of pulses for adequate protein
in combination with starches and for
fruits and vegetables what's recommended
by the World Health Organization and the
FAO and for both micronutrients and
prevention of chronic disease and I mean
even even if it were perfectly
distributed there's nowhere near enough
of these kinds of foods so a focus on
calorie production has not taken into
account food security is not taking a
check out all the foods needed for
healthy and active lives those are not
even available enough much less
accessible so color production alone not
sufficient to limit food insecurity you
can get that just from the definition
it's not sufficient to eliminate under
nutrition as we have evidence for it's
definitely not going to reduce
overweight since more calories is not
going to help the overweight problem and
again underscoring food means all
diverse foods not equal to calories so
color production not really the ideal
goal when you're talking about food
security
also gdp increase in economic growth has
also been something that agriculture
traditionally strives for but that is
also not the ideal goal when you're
talking about nutrition because as GDP
Rises there is a correlation with
stunting that poorer countries tend to
have more stunting and richer countries
have less stunting but it's the opposite
for obesity so as GDP grows our kind of
trading nutritional problems so it's it
has some correlation with under
nutrition but you know that's not that's
not the full picture and it's also not
as if we can categorize countries into
the obesity box or the undernutrition
box in most countries there are both
problems so this this is a chart of all
well these are many of the countries
that were kind of highlighted in the map
which have very high burdens of stunting
and were identified in in The Lancet
series as high priority countries for
undernutrition nearly a third of those
countries identified as high priority
under nutrition countries also have
overweight and obesity of over forty
percent so it is both problems at the
same time all over the world and so
again here's the map of stunting
sub-saharan Africa South Asia projected
increases in diabetes sub-saharan Africa
South Asia so it's you know thinking
about nutrition is the full picture and
it has a lot to do with diet quality and
so just one of the quotes from a
colleague at the International Food
Policy Research Institute sadly it seems
we've somehow managed to bypass good
health moving from hunger to obesity in
a single generation in many parts of the
world so what's going on well diets are
changing this is a picture that I took
in my research area in Tanzania I could
have taken it at any school there was
coca-cola signs on every single school
kind of the same thing that's going on
here with pouring rights and an
advertisement to your children and this
is you know there's there are cultural
changes going on around diets also
McDonald's you know I it's not as if
mcdonald's and coca-cola themselves are
causing all obesity but it's it's useful
to look at as a symbol as a
representation of cultural changes and
what's considered valuable and the kind
of food people strive to consume and and
what's available on what's cheap so
these are growing all over the world
this recently they weren't in Africa
before but again representation of
changing food environments and what that
might mean and this so this is really
what we're talking about is decline in
traditional food culture has to do with
meat and advertising also environments
has been called mcdonaldization coca
colonization this is sort of riffing on
how in many parts of the world no in
Africa sub-saharan Africa and South Asia
colonization actually was a major force
in changing dietary habits start with
and now talk about Coca colonization and
not just colonization so these play a
role in social construction of desirable
foods and places with traditional food
culture have been shown to have less
problems with obesity and there are
examples across all national income
levels Mediterranean diets South Korea
it's a good example there's some small
pockets of examples in South sub-saharan
Africa and so a globalization really
emphasizes uniformity and when you're
talking about transportation and
marketing often rejects foods not easily
easily available recognizable so part of
this decline in traditional food culture
has to do with a declining in
biodiversity
so at least 7,000 plant species have
been used for human food but today only
15 crops and eat animals provide ninety
percent of the world's calories and over
the past hundred years over ninety
percent of crop varieties have been lost
from fields and also livestock breeds
and this really has profound nutritional
consequences because it's not not only
does genetic uniformity open ourselves
to the risk of large-scale crop failure
and if you put huge food insecurity that
way but also diversity rich diversity in
our diet provides a variety of nutrients
and also phytochemicals that buffer
against both on a nutrition and chronic
disease and this is I think one of the
frontiers of nutrition science we've
established the micronutrients there's
still much much more to be done on
establishing health benefits of other
components of food so for example fiber
not a nutrient but extremely important
to nutrition and health lutein
zeaxanthin or some phytochemicals that
are now very well recognized for their
health benefits and we have many more of
those to discover and characterize and I
know Celine is going to talk some about
that in her presentation okay just a
representation here of the huge loss of
varieties of you know if you look at
specific species when you're talking
about how to transport them and sell
them 8090 years go by and they're very
few varieties that means less diversity
in terms of nutrients and phytochemicals
and then diets also have profound
impacts on other aspects beyond but of
the environment beyond biodiversity so
agriculture and climate change I think
probably everyone in the room knows the
answer to this when we're talking about
diets and climate change which causes
more greenhouse gas emissions rearing
cattle or driving cars livestock sector
eighteen percent more greenhouse gas
emissions than driving cars and it's not
just the
the you know methane production and
transportation of course this audience
will well know that it has much to do
with forest clearing for new pastures
not for just the animals themselves but
for example for the soy production in
Brazil that's going to feed animals in
China which is going to feed people
making them o Beason at risk for chronic
disease basically and then we also have
other issues of the environment and
diets how agriculture is using water
again this relates to livestock but also
other kinds of food production and water
withdrawals are again quite a serious
issue in the same areas of highest
malnutrition so we have agricultural
food systems that are not functioning
well for nutrition and they're not
functioning well for the environment so
with all of that to describe nutrition
when we look back at where nutritionists
are putting the majority of their
advocacy right now in these direct
nutrition interventions you're very
important to child survival obviously
they're not broad enough so one of the
efforts to try to to broaden this
nutrition agenda and where we need to
join forces with conservation is in in
guidance for agriculture so how does
agriculture how to do agriculture in a
way that's better for nutrition and also
better for the environment so one of the
things I've worked on recently for FAO
was to synthesize guidance for
agriculture programming on nutrition now
since this 2008 nutrition movement 2008
food crisis there have been over over 50
publications and statements from various
development institutions about how to
improve agriculture for nutrition so I
read through all of these and tried to
find what's the bottom line what are
people saying the same thing what is the
advice in general
like is it possible so the sun movement
characterized the table 1 about direct
nutrition interventions is it possible
to actually say something meaningful
about what to do in agriculture other
than just that we need to do it so my
approach to this was looking at all all
of the advice that international
development institutions have already
published and it turns out there was a
huge amount of convergence around the
main messages of what all of these
institutions were saying and they boiled
down to a set of core principles and I'm
not going to go through all of them here
today but some of the key ones I'll just
go through for the purposes of our
discussion so one of the key messages is
incorporating explicit nutrition
objectives so not just assuming that
whatever we do in agriculture growing
calories growing dollars you know
whatever we that it's going to
automatically translate to nutrition
because we know that's not true so to
start we need to say that we want
agriculture to actually do something
good for nutrition so to have that
objective and then to measure impact
through monitoring and evaluation so
it's not good enough to have an
objective but to also follow our
programs and investments doing anything
to follow steps along the way to improve
nutrition to work within context so to
take advantage of the resources that are
available in a particular place what's
possible to grow what the agro ecosystem
is what it can what resources are in
that ecosystem that could contribute to
nutrition and to build on that and more
than just coming with an outside idea or
intervention and and assuming it will
work targeting the vulnerable so we
really working with vulnerable farmers
smallholders women indigenous groups and
not only larger you know farms that
would be more efficient at calorie
production and income production the
ones in the middle in blue are ones that
were sort of core principles that
that it seemed like most institutions
we're seeing you really need to do in
every case so empowering women is is a
critical one because a lot of women are
farmers and there's very good evidence
that women's income leads very directly
to improve nutrition of all household
members more so than overall household
income or men's income there's a very
close connection between women's income
and nutrition so in probably women
economically but also their time so
reducing the time they have to spend on
many different tasks so that they can
spend that time better on the you know
caring for children and not letting the
that go by because there's so many other
tasks to do or caring for the household
these are roles that women have whether
they like it or not everywhere in the
world so women's time use is a very big
issue in addition to women's income then
incorporating nutrition education so so
partly general nutrition education you
know hygiene and behaviors but also
information about specific foods and why
to value specific foods so why you know
why some of these traditional food
resources are actually valuable
nutritional resources and not just
famine foods are not just something to
discard once you have enough money to go
buy a McDonald's so nutrition education
is something a lot of institutions said
also so this is where we really come
together it was interesting to me that
almost every institution talked about
managing natural resources as a route
from agriculture to nutrition and in all
of the different guidance notes some
various things that were brought up
where soil water biodiversity and
climate and how those relate to food
production in some of the ways that I
went over earlier and basically the
bottom line is that natural resources
are critical for the livelihoods and
resilience of vulnerable farmers and
sustainable food and nutrition security
for all so it's not enough to think
about just immediate short-term food
security we have to think long-term and
even if we're thinking about immediate
food security we're talking about
farmers living
landscapes which if resources aren't
concerned though aren't conserved those
landscapes could be non viable in the
very near future so it's both for the
present and and future talking about
natural resources and I'll come back to
this more then some of the other
principles were diversifying production
so you know not just focusing on staple
crops and increasing production of
nutrient-dense foods and also with that
increasing market access and
opportunities and this is really to say
that subsistence is not what is being
recommended if there's a recognition
that people many people are semi
subsistence subsistence but most people
really strive to earn income from their
environments and from their agriculture
so increasing those opportunities in a
way that supports those vulnerable for
their what they can produce well and and
also from what's nutritious so an
example of that is this is a project
that I worked on in East Africa where
the project was promoting traditional
African vegetables and these are very
well adapted to the environment with
very low resources there many of them
are wild foods but they can also be
cultivated in fields so this program was
trying to promote these both on the
production side and also on the
marketing side so that nutrition
education and markets principal coming
together so what this organization did
this guy is from farm concerned
international they used an approach of
nutrition focused marketing to consumers
and farmers they took these you know
wild leafy vegetables and we're
marketing them in in Nairobi
supermarkets based on their nutritional
qualities high in vitamin A high and
iron they also had in in Swahili they're
called Dawa which means medicine so they
also had medicinal characteristics a lot
of people said that they prevented
diabetes so marketing them you know to
both serve the purpose of both producing
under
nutrition and reduce problems with
obesity and chronic disease and this is
this is this wang ji from farm concerned
talking to the farmers and it wasn't
just meant by the way women are are
mostly the one who grow these vegetables
and they were targeted but there's
somehow not in this picture and this is
the same information being used in the
supermarket here with a promotion around
traditional african vegetables and we
talk about nutrition sensitive economic
growth so economic growth that promotes
diversified diets with local resources
that are sustainable to produce also
empowering women so that they have that
income to use for nutrition it's kind of
the whole package of the way that
economic growth and agriculture could
support nutrition and environment and i
know that selena is also going to talk
about this in her presentation with how
how you can use quality of food the you
know nutrition or phytochemistry to
influence consumers to demand that food
more and i also want to bring in the
these same concepts are being discussed
this was a meeting just last month where
the Sackler Institute of the new york
academy of sciences launched a new
research agenda and i was part of the
working group so i was presenting this
research agenda last month and our group
decided that this is a major this is
like the crux of the research agenda is
how to bring together nutrition
environmental sustainability and
economic profitability and that policies
and interventions and guidelines can
move these circles closer together
farther apart then there's also very
recently there's as the new UN zero
hunger challenge which has been unveiled
before as a post Millennium Development
Goals agenda and these are these are the
targets as of now they may change but
this is the you know the first version
of them so one hundred percent access to
adequate food year round
Oh stunted children all food systems are
sustainable one hundred percent increase
in smallholder farmer productivity and
income and zero loss or waste of food so
all this to say there's been a lot of
recent movement on the nutrition agenda
even more recently there's been a lot of
movement on okay that narrow agenda on
nutrients isn't enough we also need to
talk about farming and farmers
livelihoods and environmental
sustainability so there's actually quite
a lot of talk about this in the
nutrition community but especially for
the environmental sustainability peas
what how are we going to be accountable
to this so you know conservation is very
often stated but it's not part of any
nutrition results framework in a serious
way I mean the Millennium the sorry this
year hunger challenge here has all
hosted some food systems are sustainable
but what you know what does that what
kind of results are we looking for are
we just saying that what there's no
results framework I know of in a
nutrition project that would actually
measure anything having to do with
sustainability and I think when you
would say this to most nutritionists
they would say well see how sustainable
is important but it's not strongest link
to nutrition I mean it's important but
if I'm actually just going to spend my
scarce resources measuring like what I
do for nutrition and I'm probably not I
don't even know what to measure and I'm
not even sure what time scale i'm
looking for effects so i want to go
through and this is part this will lead
into the discussion that selena and i
are going to facilitate this afternoon
so as i go through these indicators that
are usually used i'd really like to have
discussion with you all about how we can
come up with indicators to be used
together that would you know so that
conservation projects could take more
account nutrition and nutrition could
somehow realist really take conservation
into account seriously so these are the
kind of
cults that are usually measured this is
again this framework of food health and
care and at the top nutritional status
is usually the you know the primary
thing that nutritionists want to measure
for nutrition impact and these are
indicators of stunting low height for
age underweight which is just being too
small for age anemia in vitamin A status
then in the next level that we we often
measure dietary quality and we can we
can talk more about these specific
indicators if you're interested but I'm
just going to give a basic overview so
dietary quality oftentimes can be
measured with individual dietary
diversity scores so you ask people it's
a very simple thing to do you you have
basically like eight or 12 food groups
and you go through and you say oh did
you eat any starches yesterday such as
rice or corn yes or no did you eat any
fruits yesterday such as yes or no and
so you can come up with a score from you
know 0 if you ain't nothing to 12 if you
ate all of the food groups and that will
and that's well correlated with dietary
quality so the higher the higher the
diversity the higher than micronutrient
and calorie adequacy of your diet and
then some people still measure nutrient
consumption but that's much less simple
that requires you know very intensive
questionnaires about what exactly you
ate and the amounts and then calculating
nutrient composition out of all those
foods but sometimes nutritionist do that
then there's food security so
unfortunately there's no one indicator
of food security if food security is a
very elusive concept and the best you
can do is to measure different aspects
of it and try to understand if your
intervention or your policy is changing
any of those aspects of food security so
no mostly when people have used a food
security indicator it's been the the FAO
indicator of calorie availability when
you look at food insecurity maps of the
world that's what it is it's calories
but obviously as you should all know and
never ever forget that doesn't represent
food security that only represents a
very small part of food security how
many calories you have so there are
other indicators of food security too
and we can go into those in detail but
but they're you know they have to do
with household dietary diversity the
kinds of weather food whether households
can access diverse diets also
experiential measures so like in the US
the way that we measure of food
insecurity is by asking people are you
worried about food did you go to bed
hungry things like that so your
experience of it so there's different
measures in this level so there's the
healthy environments level here and this
is where I put a question that we should
discuss so are there indicators I mean
there's no indicators I know of I've
used in nutrition of the healthy
helpfulness of environments which lead
to disease and dietary intake so we
might want to think about that as a
level of conservation indicators and
then down under the basic causes we
measure income and we are starting to
measure women's empowerment because
again this feedback into maternal child
care women's empowerment come up with
indicators for it because it's so
important and you know the ecosystem
services that support food security and
environments are also so important but I
don't know of any indicators to measure
them in nutrition projects so I think
what we might want to think about in
terms of okay how do we go forward
measuring how ecosystem services affect
nutrition is to think about our
objectives so aligning the objectives
between conservation and nutrition for
research priorities so we have these
various nutrition objectives improving
dietary quality increasing my street
micronutrient a
like improving maternal child care and
seating access to clean water for
drinking for washing hygiene protecting
health avoiding disease increasing
equity and increasing food security
these are all kind of basic objectives
of nutrition and conservation we have
conserving biodiversity and maintaining
ecosystem services and all of the pieces
of ecosystem services and we can start
to connect these so I mean there's a lot
of potential connections that we can
discuss but for example the ecosystem
service of freshwater obviously links to
access to clean water for drinking and
hygiene also it links to maternal child
care and feeding because water
collection is a major drain on women's
time so if you want to increase the
amount of time women have for providing
care to families as they you know need
to do no matter what you need to
decrease the amount of time they spend
on things like fetching water the same
goes for fuel fuel collection major
drain on women's time regulating
infectious disease risk for as a
potential ecosystem service that could
be measured which has a lot to do with
protecting health and in that way
improving nutrition soil has to do with
increasing food security it's a basic
foundation for crop production and also
micronutrient take depending on what's
in that soil that goes into the crowds
food obviously relates today a Terry
quality and biodiversity relates to a
whole bunch of these objectives and I
think the links there need to be
clarified in future research so some
forestry relevant models that link
ecological nutrition objectives Selena
and I talked about these and we'd like
to discuss them more with you this
afternoon but one of them would be agro
forests and the nutrition objectives
here that agri forest could reach our
food security dietary quality and income
integrated forest IRA cultural
landscapes could have to do with equity
and they have to do a dietary quality
again and income mixed cropping could
have to do with nutrition objectives of
food security and dietary quality and
again like these could have to do a lot
more nutrition objective
but these are just the first ones to cut
that that come to mind and structurally
and functionally diverse gardens have a
lot to do with dietary equality and
women's empowerment there's actually a
fair amount of literature on this in the
new in the nutrition world home gardens
and nutrition outcomes and then tree
planting equity women's empowerment
dietary quality if you're talking about
certain kinds of trees that grow
nutritious foods and I just AM
referencing the green belt movement here
because one Gary Matai one of her
initial objectives with the tree
planting had to it was intimately tied
with women's empowerment and then that
empowerment being very important to the
well-being of households and partly
through their nutrition so I think
there's a lot of links that we can make
but we need to show them so we need to
show how forests be to ecosystem
services and how those connect to
nutrition and we need to then improve
our messages too so that I mean I think
we are stronger at changing the shape of
Agriculture together through both
nutrition and conservation we need to
improve our messages on how how we're
linked together and then to generate
evidence along this pathway to influence
policy and I'll just introduce very
briefly the one of the one of the
messages that has bit has been started
to be promoted it's still not used a
whole lot but one of fao s messages on
these links is sustainable diets and fa
a--'s definition of this is diets with
low environmental impacts which
contribute to food and nutrition
security and to healthy life for present
and future generations sustainable diets
are protective and respectful of
biodiversity and ecosystems cultural
acceptable accessible economically fair
affordable nutritionally adequate safe
and healthy and optimizing nutrition and
human resources so this was definitely
put together by a committee I mean it's
a very so the message the message of
sustainable diets probably is a good one
maybe could be further clarified so that
people understand what it means but I
think it does
start to bring together the nutrition
and conservation agendas so we need some
metrics to influence decisions bio
versity has a research agenda on
sustainable diets metrics and we need to
think together with the forestry
community on what ecological metrics
nutrition can use what nutrition
indicators that could be relevant and
applicable in forestry because what gets
measured gets managed and otherwise if
we're not measuring we're just going to
continue to use the stain ability as a
word that would be nice and I hope that
if i leave you with only one thing that
you'll remember is in your projects in
your research and your analysis do not
use calorie availability as synonymous
with nutrition because that will just
continue to lead us down the wrong path
of things ways of production that are
not supporting nutrition and are not
supporting conservation so again in our
discussion this afternoon we're going to
talk with you about how to join forces
effectively what policies and one
institutions do we need to work with we
have agreements such as this zero hunger
challenge we have networks such as the
scaling up nutrition the red program we
have global institutions such as the UN
the world bank and the CGR institutions
we have regional institutions like the
African Conference of agriculture
development program national and local
level so where is it that we can join
forces effectively in all these
different levels so I think to end that
nutrition with in conservation it really
epitomizes a people-centred approach and
I think people centered approaches are
are what moves policy you know
orangatang can only move policy so much
I think people centred approaches are
really what policymakers mostly strive
for and that nutrition is all about
human growth and human potential and
health and this is important to force
you because it really shows that it's
not people versus forest as was said in
the keynote yesterday but it's that
people need to
it's people with for US Senate force are
essential 12 people and provide
essential ecosystem services so I think
we need to work together more and talk
more and I think there's no better place
than to start them here today at this
conference thank you um we have time for
some quick clarifying questions um we'll
also have her in the panel so keep that
in mind if we don't have time to get to
your question I know okay so if it's
only a clarifying question here we yeah
okay it for a clarifying question on the
bar chart your showed of the three food
categories and sub-saharan Africa and
how much are being produced and how much
we need had two questions so first of
all it was was that you said that
there's enough grains and starchy roots
produced to actually feed it the
distribution was fair woodall as all of
that what's being produced actually
staying in Africa so is that only
looking at domestic markets or is that
stuff that will largely maybe go
overseas Oh a great question my eye
sorry right away the other question is
you only showed pulses as and how much
we need to meet protein requirements so
is that pulse equivalent of protein or
are you suggesting that pulses would be
sufficient to meet protein requirements
without animal sources at all okay yeah
so just to clarify those points the all
those all those different food
categories included starchy roots and
pollen grains those are all food
available it within countries so those
you could also look at food production
which is stuff for export as well as
domestic but that was specifically food
available in the country so it's not
leaving the country or the region in
this case and then with pulses that that
calculation was how much would be
available
in combination with starches to meet
protein so there's no need there's no
nutritional need for animal products for
adequate protein a lot of times animal
products are expedient for protein but
there's actually no nutritional need for
animal products you know for tor meeting
protein requirement you can meet your
protein requirements with pulses plus
grains so that's what that calculation
was it was assuming just for the sake of
simplicity assuming no animal source
food consumption and of course now when
you add animal source food consumption
it would go down a little bit but
they're on average in sub-saharan Africa
animal sourced food consumption is very
low so just showing yeah what what would
be needed to increase sort of most
quickly and with the fewest resources to
reach protein requirements
but maybe that's for the panel I don't
know so I agree with everything you said
when you describe the situation when you
report facts but in spite of that I
really disagree with the Euro
commendation policy recommendation like
for example I think that I keep on
thinking that the calories is really the
big the big issue in food security and
that it's the one wait it's the right
way to go not why not the wrong way to
go but there's a panel so maybe that's
better something to keep for the panel
right okay so so I would stop there so I
like to hear why you think that it would
be a good idea going forward because I
think a lot of people agree with you so
we should have that conversation ok so
in the panel yeah thank you so much and
if the presenters for a panel one and
the moderator can join us on stage and
can take a seat too thanks
yeah good idea
hello can everybody hear me I use that
I'd like to welcome everyone to the
first panel of the meeting which is
called beyond yields food security and
resilience and the way the organizers
have told me the way this is going to
work is that each talk will be 10
minutes and then there will be five
minutes for questions if this is
incorrect one of the organizers let me
know because sometimes I just make
things up and then after all three talks
we will have a panel discussion for an
hour or so our first speaker today is
Saleem Ahmed are you ready Selena got
her bachelor's degree in economics from
Barnard College and then she went and
got a master's degree in ethnobotany
from University of Kent I think she
brings a very interesting perspective to
the study of the relationship between
people and plants because of those two
parts of her background she's currently
a lecturer at Dartmouth College
wassailing you have all this stuff she's
also a postdoctoral fellow at Tufts
University a visiting fellow at the
Arnold Arboretum I'd like to hear about
that and a foreign expert at menza
University and Beijing Selena also did
her PhD with me as a professor so so I
just about any responsibility for
anything that serious
hurt her talk this morning is I guess as
part of your doctor will work right some
of them absolutely which is called
beyond yields managing tiagra forests
for crop quality food security and
climate change resilience Selena on it
thank you yeah
it's next one
insomnia
thank you dr. Peters for the
introduction it's an honor to be here
today to join in the dialogue on one
food and forests with a case study on
tiagra forests I'm going to be building
on some of the framework that dr.
Harford presented in the opening address
in two in 1999-2000 three the Chinese
government implemented one of the
largest conservation programs in the
world which incorporated agricultural
systems and given some the joint
objectives of Agriculture and
conservation it could also be a really
great opportunity to target nutrition
outcomes and so in this talk I'm in a
present a case study that compares the
Chinese government's green for green
program to some of the indigenous
agricultural systems that were replaced
or in some cases overlooked by this
program i'm specifically focusing on t
agroecosystems where the chinese
government paid subsidies to farmers to
replace indigenous systems with cash
cropping which was considered as forest
cover by the government policy so it
conducted research in southwestern
yunnan province near the border of Burma
and Laos in monkey County this is part
of the endo Burma hotspot of
biodiversity I was working with the aqha
sociolinguistic group and I was working
in two neighboring communities that both
historically managed tiagra forests and
then one in the past decade had
transitioned to managing terrorist tree
plantations as part of the green for
green program and had replaced their
tiagra forests to the talk starts off
with beyond deals and if we're looking
just at yields it's very clear why the
Chinese government would promote and
intensify terrace tree plantation and
why farmers may even be attracted to
converting their
indigenous systems to these modern
terraces there's more than four times
the amount of yield if you're just
talking about one single species within
the system which is t coming from the
terraces however a building on dr. her
for its framework of really moving
beyond yield and integrating ecological
and dietary indicators were going to be
examining these systems are based on
several different parameters including
species diversity structural and
functional diversity genetic diversity
dietary diversity and one thing that I
really focuses it on is by the chemical
quality of the crops themselves just to
give a little bit more context about the
two communities that I'm working with
they both are about have 100 households
and it's not just tiagra ecosystems that
they're managing it's within a whole
mosaic of other sorts of land use so the
community that primarily manages Agri
forests has about thirty two different
land-use types including forest and rice
paddies and mixed crop fields and the
community that manages Terrace
plantations historically also had about
thirty land-use types but more recently
has really transitioned into more
terrorist ian has intensified with that
so there's more simplification in the
landscape with eleven land-use types but
still it's a mosaic of different land
uses and just sort of looking at the
structural complexity of ecological
samples within these systems the agro
forest has much more performance system
which as we all know has many is related
to a lot of ecosystem services such as
pollination services soil protection
watershed protection and looking at it
from a plant species perspective plots
within the Agri forest and the forested
buffer should also shows that there's a
lot more plant species diversity within
the Agri forest in addition to the
terrorist plantations and focusing just
on food species so we here we see that
there's about
228 species overall in the agroforestry
system and 79 of those are specifically
food plans so we really expect greater
dietary diversity from that community
that's really relying on the Agri forest
system and that represents about 35
different families some of the most
representative I Gacy Lucy rose AC and
more AC um and so having this sort of
rich diversity in the landscape you
would expect this to come onto the table
and see lots of yummy dishes that really
represent the local biodiversity which
is indeed the case which I'll be talking
about that and so looking at not to
species diversity but also looking at
genetic diversity geographers have a
wider genetic diversity than the
monocultures because those rely on
clonal propagules whereas farmers for
the Agri forest actually go out into
wild forest populations where they take
different germplasm of wild relatives
and incorporate them into their I go
forest and this has resulted in a spread
of traits that you can see just within a
small tiagra forest farmers may manage
up to 15 different varieties of tea that
a botanist would identify all is one
species but they actually may have 15
different names for these and they
manage them for different
characteristics
um so sort of moving and linking the
ecological indicators with the nutrition
indicators a phytochemical quality is
one really good way of doing this
because plants produce secondary
metabolites as defense compounds so
these really have an environmental role
plants won't produce them and then
unless they have ecological cue to do so
so if you sort of remove the ecological
cue to produce these secondary
metabolites plants will be producing
them and as dr. herfurth was saying some
of these phytochemicals also have been
implicated in prevention of chronic
disease so this is one good indicator to
sort of start to link environmental
services with nutrition indicators and
so looking at I did hplc analysis of tea
samples from the two different systems
for a total catechin content cadogan's
are the compounds that give the
antioxidant properties of tea and there
was over twice the amount of antioxidant
properties 40 samples from the agri
forest compared to the terrorist
plantations I'm I also did this firm at
the xanthine compounds on and saw the
same thing so methylxanthines are the is
like caffeine and one of the reasons why
t is the most consumed beverage in the
world after water so the tea that's
produced in this area is known as poo
air and it really became popular about
ten years ago where the prices of poor
became quite exponential and consumers
really started to seek to where
specifically from tiagra forest because
of the phytochemical quality of this
particular tea and this is indicated
very well in the price this is the
dollars per kilo of dried cheese so a
tea that was from terrace plantations
and tea that was from Agri forest had
the same price about 2000 2001 2002 and
then in 2003 kazoo
knowledge of the higher quality of agri
foresty led to this huge market demand
which really leads to this new
livelihoods that farmers are receiving
and despite this price bus that sort of
happened in 2008 with this over a
marketing of tea that traders marketed
as being from Agri forest and some sort
of consumer unwillingness to pay the
market has bounced back and consumers
continue to pay a price premium 44 agri
forest so this is some of the most
expensive tea in the world
so markets are always changing and
farmers need to be cognizant off this
but also the environment is also
continuously changing so I'm just in the
past 50 years farmers have already
experienced a change in temperature and
precipitation at the study site during
the spring harvest there has already
been fourteen percent more precipitation
rainfall than was expected or that had
happened 50 years ago and then during
the monsoons are also getting more
extreme so monsoons are really linked to
the phytochemical quality of the tea tea
grown in the dry season is considered
sort of the highest quality I'm and then
there's this big drop in the
phytochemistry when the monsoons hit and
this is linked to a reduction in pharma
livelihoods when the prices are reduced
by about a half and so it's really
important to sort of have ecological
conditions and management conditions to
grow tea in a way that it's not as
vulnerable to climate risk with
increased precipitation and this is just
looking at climate change expectations
in the next 50 years on what's
interesting is it's actually supposed to
get drier in the dry season and wetter
during the monsoon season so here I
sampled a tea samples during the onset
of the East Asian monsoon following one
of the most severe droughts in recorded
history in southern Yunnan and then I
sampled during the onset of the monsoon
itself and then in the monsoon season
and then I sort of compare the
phytochemical quality for these
different periods as a proxy measure for
climate change because we can't all but
obviously measure how climate was 50
years ago I'm also coupling this with
greenhouse experiments manipulating
climate change but it's also important
to sort of find a way in natural
ecosystems to have extreme weather
patterns like sort of mimic climate
change and here we saw that the decline
of Chi in both the systems declined
however tifa mangrove forest had less of
a decline in total total khattak and
content than tea from terrorists
plantations which i think is really
interesting so again there was less of a
quality drop during the monsoons because
of the way agri forests are managed and
even though this talk is titled beyond
yield I do want to talk about yield over
here because farmers reported that while
tea from terraces had a decline because
of the drought for about one-half to
one-third less and they usually
experience during the spring chief from
agri force actually farmers didn't
really experience the drop in yield so
even though we're not talking about
yields I go for us actually had less of
a hit for yields with the drought so
again talking about the resilience of
the structure of the system
um and household surveys with farmers
sort of indicated that farmers do have
knowledge of management practices to
sort of reduce climate vulnerability
maintaining canopy coverage maintaining
forested buffers around the
agroecosystems and really maintaining or
cultivating tea plants as trees rather
than shrubs really helps alleviate a
climate risk so sort of this coupling of
farmer knowledge climate variability in
agroecosystems really centered around T
quality and the prices that farmers
receive for higher quality have really
enabled farmers to sort of conserve the
biological diversity in their ecosystems
so I have just a minute left so we're
going to sort of skip the dietary divest
diversity slides but I just want to sort
of leave you with this thought what
would it mean if giant policies such as
the green for green policy instead of
started promoting a system like this
what would it mean for conservation and
you Trisha and how feasible would it be
if it promoted a system like this thank
you
questions yes
you talk a little more about the price
differential between agroforestry and
the terrorist II and what the market was
for the like 10 times higher price T and
how that could influence local
availability of T if it all kind of had
a higher price and so um can you repeat
the two parts of your question what the
market was for the higher price t and
the implications for local markets if
the t is all higher priced if it all
moved towards the agroforestry system
okay so i sort of the market for the t
there was not so much for price
differential between and terrace tea and
then in two thousand
which pesticides and herbicides which is
what a terrorist monoculture has whereas
the agroforestry alee relies on the
ecosystem services and doesn't have
these chemical inputs so people began to
look for other types of tea or to go in
a different way that doesn't have this
and so that's one reason why the
differential started to occur between
agri forest and terrace plantation so it
was really consumer knowledge of
understanding the quality difference and
then the second factor at play was
really government promotion of tea so
that was a sustainable development
effort to promote tea so the government
had a lot of infrastructure in Yunnan
Province to enable the markets to grow
so it's really the coupling of consumer
knowledge as well as sort of government
promotion of tea that enabled that sort
of price structure to develop that way
um and then the second part of your
question yes so what does that meant for
local tea production tea has greatly
expanded with in Yunnan a sort of a tea
fication process and in the two
different sites that i was working at
the site that manages agri forests are
expanding their agri forests tiagra
forest and the sites that sort of have
terrace tea plantations aren't
increasing those anymore so even though
now there's this big price difference
it's a lot easier to sell tea from an
aqua forest then it is too salty from a
monoculture I thank you for your talk I
was wondering if you had a biophysical
explanation for why you're finding these
biochemical differences between the two
types of tea thank you sure I'll open it
out to any other theories in the
audience first well I would tea from an
agroforestry do small phytochemicals
than tea from a terrorist plantation
sort of thinking back to these
phytochemicals being defense compound to
the plant produces that I'm expensive
for the plant to produce and they'll
only produce it at they have sort of
ecological cue to do so so why would you
expect a Nagra forest to have more of
these compounds
anybody want to answer that yes dr.
peter is so cool a predator where is
what you eat some people I can tell you
that by hiding yourself among 200 others
between planets you can somehow avoid
predation and not have to invest that
energy to produce phytochemicals that's
it what is the answer so that's greater
in direction so I my theory is that
plants in the agro or in the terrace
plantation don't have the ecological cue
to produce these compounds because they
have pesticides and so they don't need
to produce these expensive compounds
because they're kind of being pampered
and if they don't have pesticides the
plants will be defoliated so that's my
theory
organic compound mm-hmm
neighbors can cue each other in to
produce them in the event of predation
yes so the particular compounds that are
quantified or not those type of foot
they're not aromatic compounds but it
could be within the soil there so there
can be communication with other plans
yes yes so the the income that each
system is going to produce we depend on
the yield but also on the area how many
actors you can do with each system
depends on the price depends on the
subsidy you get from the government then
there's also the risk issues etc so in
the end which system provides more
income potentially to the farmers and
which system to the farmer prefer and if
they prefer the new system they put low
value on the future benefit of being
resilient for example and if they prefer
to have straight white now good income
in case it provides more income so if
they prefer the new system what what
should we do and that goes together with
that question I would not expect that
they could plant the same area of tea
with the new system than with the old
one because the new system is more
intensive I guess it requires more level
so it might be that they could not
anyway convert all the land into the new
system just because of lab or
requirements so what about combining the
two system and talking about resilience
diversity is also combining different
systems together so what about also the
this option absolutely thank you for
your questions you might remind me some
of your questions so to start off with
which system sort of wins absolutely the
agri forest system wins in terms of
income farmers receive more than 10 to
15 times the amount of income and it's
not just the price of the tea but it's
also the demand for the tea so the
farmers that grow the terrorist t they
can't sell a lot of their tea of a year
now there's sort of over infiltration of
too much terrorist tea in the market in
yunnan but with the igo forest it's
actually not enough so there is just you
know it gets sold all the time there's
just no
so there really is a need in terms of
demand to expand the Agri four assists
em so I'm certainly in terms of income
the agroforestry system wins and in
terms of farmer sort of preferences for
the systems so they're both aqua
communities that I worked with and they
do prefer the traditional Agri Forest
System it really is part of their
cultural identity it's sort of agrarian
management practices that resonate with
what they've been doing historically um
so I think such a system does take into
consideration the cultural context of
the farmers um and why did the other
farmers sort of transition to the new
system part of that is because it was a
sort of the price differential was in
that big when the program was
implemented and so farmers you know you
do not you're not sure what's going to
happen but now what I'm seeing when i go
back to you non is that actually farmers
that once had Agri for us I converted
them into these monocultures are
actually starting to convert them back
into their like removing their clonal
propagules starting to put in you know
their traditional seed their traditional
and races so there is the landscape is
really fluid which is good to see new on
forest they were offered they were
offered to participate in this program
so there was some land use changes that
had happened that some of the
traditional systems weren't allowed to
be implemented but they were sort of
offered these subsidies
the subsidies are gone together
subsidies were like a ten year yeah
okay our next speaker is Sarah oyster
hoot and she's a Coleman fellow here in
that school of forest in terminal
studies and she is a doctoral student in
the joint program between the school
forestry and in verbal studies and
anthropology department of anthropology
at Yale I'm also on her committee this
is like I know the title of her talk is
food forest markets meanings vanilla
agroforestry systems of northeastern
Madagascar please be very kind to Sarah
she just broke her foot sir
dr. Peters can you hear me
if there's not enough pressure I'll try
to do this balancing on one foot
so thank you all for coming and thank
you for the organizers of the conference
for putting together such a great event
and for inviting me to speak this
morning I will discuss some of my
dissertation research which examines the
environmental and the cultural
dimensions of vanilla and clove
agroforestry systems in the monon our
region of northeastern madagascar so the
laminar region is within Madagascar is
rainforest corridor which stretches up
the East Coast families in this area are
mostly smallholder farmers here usually
I learned about three or four parcels of
land on hillsides that they cultivate as
agroforestry systems these are great
systems they integrate subsistence crops
market crops fruit trees temporaries
firewood species and medicinal plants
the main market crops in modern are our
vanilla and cloves they are cultivated
only for export markets and been in the
area more or less about 80 years they
also farm rice in this area often in
lowland rice paddies that are irrigated
but also as sweden systems on hillsides
this rice that people grow they
supplement with rice that they by using
the income from cloves and vanilla and
this income is also used for other food
security measures such as buying dried
beans and other other things to eat so
I'll admit up front that I am an
anthropologist and most of my field
research is doing anthropology and
ethnography with these small-scale
farmers but while I was conducting my
field research and anthropology I was so
struck by how how amazing these systems
seem to me and diversities agroforestry
systems looking on the middle slide
we're not looking over a protected area
or any sort of park these are managed
forests agricultural systems and that
little bit of green in the middle you
see is Bryce and I knew though if I came
back as an anthropologist and said oh
what pretty forest that might not carry
much weight so I really want to look at
what was going on in these agroforestry
systems more systematically
to do this I conducted surveys of
agroforestry fields that farmers managed
for vanilla and cloves I worked with
seven farmers we surveyed 5 10 by 10
meter plots in the vanilla gardens from
each farmer giving a total of
thirty-five plots we also collected
specimens for each species which we
identified with help from botanist at
the University of antananarivo go over
quickly some of the results of these
seven farmers recorded 89 different tree
species with a dbh greater than 5
centimeters if you add in the tree
species that repulse with a height over
2 meters and a dbh of less than 5
centimeters this total species of trees
goes to 97 tree species these trees
represent 39 different families about
thirty-five percent of these species are
native and/or endemic I also spoke with
people about the uses of each of these
types of trees people cited at least one
cultural or environmental use for all 97
tree species many of these are
subsistence purposes such as fruit trees
jack fruit mango lychee breadfruit and
avocado for example they also contain
palm species included coconuts and
raffia the refuse in the middle here
it's a palm that's used to destruct
homes and also for weaving mats and
baskets there's also a lot of cheese
used for construction furniture making
and firewood and also medicinal uses and
that all of these is that people told me
about were utilitarian there was also a
lot of ecological roles people told me
that the trees are playing in their
fields such as soil improvement bird
habitat or lemur foods an example is
this tree on the right called uncle via
which is an endemic tree that people
that provides food for birds ananka via
is often used as a vanilla Tudor tree as
well which brings me to vanilla Tudor
trees so vanilla is in orchid actually
it's native to mess of America and it's
extremely labor-intensive
very difficult to cultivate it requires
a precise blend of shade and Sun threads
growing cycle all the flowers have to be
hand pollinated too when people
cultivate them they wrap them around
trees that are called tutor trees and
these are living trees that support the
vine and grow with the vine a good tutor
tree is relatively small in diameter and
about two meters in height this is a
view of a typical vanilla garden those
are the tutor trees and these represent
a significant number of stems from on
average the farmers I surveyed had seven
hundred vanilla vines are so growing in
these five parcels and each vanilla vine
needs its own tutor tree so that's seven
hundred stems in the fields I surveyed
the tree called alibre which is Patrick
labbra of Bombay siiii was the most
prevalent Twitter tree over all those
seventy three different types of trees
were used at least once as a vanilla
tutor I also looked at importance values
for each tree species in each for each
farmer which takes an account the
relative number frequency and basal area
this is data from former one from some
of data from her field and cloves is her
most important species followed by the
tutor tree alibre and these results are
indicative of many of the farmers other
important value species were jackfruit
coconut coffee and the endemic tree on
Polly of the Murray see so there was
some variation among farmers regarding
the number of tree species in their
fields down here for example farmer six
or farmer five that's more ten managed
59 of the 89 species while farmer seven
this is Frank Cain shown here had a
lower diversity of 17 types of trees
which is still impressive actually to
manage although she had fewer number of
species she did have some interesting
things in her field including black
pepper and cacao which used to be crops
of commercial value in the region but
aren't anymore
and she was the only one that still had
cacao growing in her fields of the
fields I surveyed which raises an
interesting point while there are a
dozen or so tree species found in all
farmers fields like coffee coconut
cetera the tree species profile for the
rest of the species really vary
depending on the farmer ensure each
farmer had kind of favorite trees that
they would encourage and this preference
encourages an overall landscape
diversity when you're taken across a
more regional scale also looked at rank
abundance curves you can see here for
each of the seven farmers and looking at
these curves they're very similar to
what we were expect to find and what we
think of as quote natural forests and
show this long curve at the end this
illustrates that there are a lot of
species that are only represented by one
or two individuals and overall this kind
of curve suggests that the forest is
resilient to disruption and change and
while we look at these curves and think
of mana Nara it's important to note that
mana Nara is no stranger to disruption
and change it's right in the path of
violent cyclones it has periods of
drought and flooding and additional to
invite in addition environmental
disturbances there's lots of market
fluctuations vanilla especially is an
extremely volatile and unpredictable
market and there's also i should add
political disturbances such as the
recent coup so what can we conclude from
these studies Madagascar receives a lot
of attention for its high rates of
biodiversity and endemism especially in
this rain forest corridor of the east
coast this diversity we hear is
extremely threatened most notably by
small-scale farmers who practiced within
agriculture another cited threat to
forest is the introduction of cash crops
which are often assumed to encourage
monocrop systems better Road both
cultural and environmental diversity but
the vanilla and clove force of manan are
challenged these ideas these
preconceptions here in montanaro market
crops are cultivated in
verse systems that have many of the same
ecological characteristics of natural
forests far as keep the farmers keep
their commitment to diverse landscapes
even in the face of extreme market
fluctuations this challenge is the
assumption that farmers will abandon
market crops when commodity prices fall
or that one commodity prices spike up
that they'll just go and clear their
field and only plant this one important
market krub another protest people say
about agroforestry fields as yeah these
are fine they're sort of cute but
there's no way these these systems can
meet global demand for commodities they
can't produce commodities on a global
scale and again montanaro overturns it
Smith mana Nara is a huge producer of
clothes actually it's the largest
production region in Madagascar and
Madagascar is one of the largest clove
exporters in the world and this
production is meant only by small-scale
farmers who collect clothes by hand bud
by bud any boonies that go by dugout
canoe two pickups to market there are no
clove plantations in this region so
overall the vanilla and clove forest of
mana Nara tell an optimistic story of
cultivation systems that are able to
balance cash crops and subsistence crops
while maintaining the land ownership of
small-scale farmers as well as
encouraging forest cover and
biodiversity so how do they do it why
have such diverse robust and successful
agroforestry systems developed in this
region it's a complicated question and
when I look at a lot in my dissertation
where I say we must look at these
landscapes not only as environmental
landscapes but as cultural landscapes
and ideological landscapes these are
landscapes that not only have a
diversity of materials but also of
meanings and hopefully you'll read more
in my dissertation which I promise is
coming any day now um but for day for
today I'll just leave with the short
answer that D it happens slowly people
in modern artists
add themselves as tree farmers tree
farming is a patient enterprise they
speak with pride about these landscapes
which they call alum bulli which is
planted forest farmers understand the
nature of commodity prices that they've
seen over time go up and down and up
again they are no stranger to cyclones
and hungry seasons and they know the
value of having backup plans and backup
plans to these backup plans for food and
for income this valuing of diversity is
expressed by a proverb that people often
cited to me in my field research kakazu
maurice-africa it lotsa Hanuman and
Nikki if you are climbing a tree with
many branches you will never have far to
fall thank you